die frage wird am ende bei allen
konzepten und die es geht und wird in
der frage liegen bei vielen dieser
forderungen die zum teil sehr radikal
vorgetragen werden welchen grad der
radikalität gehen wir mit so und ich
sage mal als volkspartei ist für uns die
frage eben auch von
sozialverträglichkeit ist für uns die
frage von arbeitsplätzen hat eben auch
eine relevanz und wir wollen eine
antwort darauf geben die beides in den
blick nimmt und nicht sagt wir gehen da
ganz radikal nur in die eine in die eine
richtung die anmutung die dort sozusagen
mit blick auf die cdu es hat ja auch csu
hat auch spd betroffen
die dort zum ausdruck gebracht wird
ich sag mal die im grunde genommen allen
mitgliedern gegenüber signalisiert alle
die sich bei cdu csu spd engagieren
sie sind entweder sozusagen irgendwie
minderbemittelt oder versuchen die
zukunft dieses landes zu zerstören
empfinde ich wirklich als ein schlag ins
gesicht von menschen die sich zum
großteil neben ihrem beruf ehrenamtlich
für dieses land engagiert
als die nachricht kam dass ich eine
ganze reihe von youtube an
zusammengeschlossen haben um einen
aufruf zu starten wahlaufruf gegen cdu
und spd habe ich mich gefragt was wir
eigentlich in diesem land los wenn eine
reihe von 370 zeitungsredaktionen zwei
tage vor der wahl erklärt hätten wir
machen einen gemeinsamen aufruf welt
bitte nicht cdu und spd es wäre klare
meinungsmache vor der wahl gewesen und
ich glaube es hätte eine muntere
diskussion in diesem land ausgelöst und
die frage stellt sie schon mit blick auf
das thema meinungsmacher was sind
eigentlich regeln aus dem analogen
bereich und welche regeln gelten
eigentlich für den digitalen bereich ja
oder nein das ist eine sehr grundlegende
frage über die wir uns unterhalten
werden und zwar nicht nur wir in der cdu
und mit der cdu sondern ich bin mir ganz
sicher in der gesamten medienpolitischen
und auch demokratie theoretischen
diskussionen der nächsten zeit
wird das eine rolle spielen und deswegen
werden wir diese diskussion auch sehr
offensiv angehen